One feature of shadows that is not captured well by basic shadow mapping is how
lights truly cast shadows. All lights have an area, but shadow mapping assumes
the light comes from an infinitesimal point. Unless the real light itself has
an extremely small filament and no diffusing bulb surface, treating it as a
point of light is a weak approximation at best. The area fully in shadow, where
no part of the light is visible, is called the umbra. Real lights cast shadows
with areas that are neither fully in shadow nor fully in light. This area of
the shadow is called the penumbra. An interesting way to look at the problem is
from the point of view of a location in the penumbra, however much of the area
of the light is visible correlates to how much light the location receives. For
example, the green point on the ground here can see about half of the emitter
above, so it will receive about half the emitter's light. You have the worry
about the angle of the surface normal to the light, the light's distribution of
energy and so on, but the major factor is how much of the light's surface is
visible to each point.